this is animal in its version sea this
is built by a company in Zurich and
we've been working with for quite some
time now that is a spin-off of the eth
university in Zurich one of the main
difference between working with animal
and the spot robot is that we have we
have access to the low level controllers
in this robot well for uh for spots we
don't have access to The Locomotion
controller so this shout out to Boston
Dynamics please
make this accessible and we can do a lot
more with your Hardware so today I'll
I'll tell you a bit more about how we do
control for legged locomotion
so this is how we control the limbs of
robots with legs so that they can
navigate environments that are flat and
beyond flat I mean the interesting parts
are you know where you need to do
Dynamic Maneuvers and sort of uh scale
obstacles jump off boxes and whatnot
currently there are two prevalent
approaches to it one of them is model
predictive controls and the other one
that I'll focus a bit on would be
reinforcement learning
so that way you get the robots of work
it out for itself exactly yeah that's
the whole point so this is MPC MPC is
kind of on the more traditional control
side of the spectrum right you have
models of your system and then you can
in essence simulate forward your model
and decide whether what your control
input would result into and then that's
whether what your what you're asking the
robot to do is successful or Not by some
Metric to see how this is done let's
let's think of a robot system robot
quadruped this is the robot body and
it's got four legs right this is one of
the four legs without going into too
much detail robot moves forward let's
say leg has three degrees of freedom
three degrees of freedom it means that
it has three ways in which it can move
right it has three joints that in most
cases are actuated by three motors now
each degree of freedom is one variable
that we need to control
and for the entire system if we consider
a robot with uh four legs three degrees
of Venom per leg then we have 12 degrees
of freedom for the joints and then we
have six more division of Freedom about
where the uh where the base position is
with respect to the world now we model
what each joint needs to do and one way
to go about this is to model that as a
polynomial a polynomial would be a way
of representing a curve let's say
against time and be that Q be the
position of one joint in model
predictive control we would have a set
of polynomials that would orchestrate
how the robot moves and then we would
look at a time Horizon let's say capital
T and then forward simulate the system
see what it does in the environment that
it navigates and then for example play
out t h which is the Horizon we can Loop
through that and repeat that multiple
times and as time flows we sort of
command the robots to do what it might
and this helps us deal with the things
like sensory noise actuation noise
estimation
uncertainty and so on drawbacks we need
to have good models of the system and
this is uh particularly difficult
especially if we're dealing with a
system that you know is operating a
dynamic environment is out in the world
you have things like wear and tear of
Motors or of fits or actually waiters
themselves you have vibrations from
making and breaking contact you make and
break contact all the time which is an
an added complication so this is this is
the kind of analytical approach the sort
of more control heavy approach now on
the other side we have a sort of I think
it's fair to say more recent development
on the machine learning side of uh of
control where uh
we train a neural network as
everyone these days the idea here is
that this being annual Network these are
nodes this is input and this is output
so we want to input the state of the
system and get us outputs uh uh a vector
of control inputs be that Torx position
desired positions desirable losses and
so on that accomplish a a Target that we
set for the robot for the system in many
cases this would be being robust to
external perturbations pushes uh long
story short the robot's not tumbling
over not falling and stepping on where
it is supposed to step
the great benefit to that is that okay
to start with this operates in uh with
data right we would learn these controls
from data and the great benefit with
that is that we can simulate examples uh
episodes that we learn from so we can
simulate the robot moving in a in an
environment that we control and we can
collect data of the robot performance
and the uh the controller performance in
the simulation
we can leave that run sort of overnight
let's say or have a cluster that uses uh
that forcing that can do the simulations
asynchronously and then we can use this
Corpus of data to learn variable bus
controllers there is a complication when
taking this from the simulation to the
real robot this is this is known as the
Sim to real transfer problem
there are a couple of ways that we can
we can work through that one of it is
double down on the machine learning
approach and learn and learn from data a
model of how the system responds to our
input and the other approach is to
actually bake that in into a into a
controller learning so instead of
learning with one particular model in
simulation we have a range of models
that we if think of it as a range where
we can sort of have knobs for each
variable of the system imagine having a
model of a quadruped where we can twist
a knob and get longer legs or shorter
legs or larger bodies we don't change
the morphology so we would not change
the degrees of freedom we would change
the the the variables of the simulator
itself so by adding these variants we
can make the controller robust against
changes in that parameters and these are
the set of parameters that are hard to
estimate from the real system and
accurately approximate in the simulator
so we can make our controllers or bus to
variations of these parameters which
means that it can transfer to uh at a
somewhat different model which is the
model that it's not the model it's a
real system right okay so can we see
some of this is that possible absolutely
yeah we have one of our quadrupeds
downstairs in the lab and we can show
you what the robot does in in in working
over some of sort of our Benchmark
obstacles
and we can also have a look at what the
robot sees how the robot person how the
robot models its surroundings and where
it decides to step and so on
so this is quadrupled robot right this
is animal version C its name is coyote
it's uh one of the robots in our lab the
research that we do here with we're
looking into machine learning approaches
to a legged Locomotion this is quite
different from traditional approaches
that use for example module based
control or model predictive control
there is a kind of convergence in the
fields at the moment we we are working
and we're seeing a lot of approaches
that combine model predictive
controllers and and learned aspects to
these controllers
now sit here is going to demonstrate our
RL based learning controller right this
is a control that has been trained uh in
simulation having a set of examples
shown to a neural network that learns to
control the system and after having it
trained then we can run it on the robot
and evaluate its performance
so you've got projection now it's kind
of a similar to where we're standing
isn't it so what's going on there
exactly so we can these are the lidar
returns from the lidar sensor that said
on the back of the robot and then on the
robot there's four depth sensors that
are distributed around the body and this
is the estimate of the system of how the
ground looks around its feet and with
that the controller can decide where to
place its uh its legs at least an
estimate so there's still the robot can
still stumble and sort of
a place fit at the sort of opposition
where it's sort of three minutes away
almost yeah the goal here is to have a
controller that is also robust to
sleeping that plank could be wet it
could be slippery yeah exactly yeah or a
stumbling and so on this is animal and
its version see this is built by a
a company in Zurich that builds robots
and we've been working with for quite
quite some time now that is a spin-off
of the eth university in Zurich we
talked about different methods of
learning upstairs the reinforcement any
other model but where does that fit in
with doing that then is that then you've
not got a static kind of uh equation
that you plug all those numbers into it
works differently doesn't it yeah
exactly so this is this is uh uh this
annual Network that then online receives
uh perception information from the
joints and the torque sensors and the
vision and depth sensors and then
decides where to place fit and how to
orchestrate the motion of all the
actuators in order to be able to
coordinate the system into walking over
things and instead going up flights of
steps and going down flights of steps
and so on
and so is it learning as it goes or is
it is that then a it's already done the
learning and then you've applying that
to this yes in this particular
controller this is the learning has been
done and it's not learned as it goes but
we're currently looking into approaches
that we can uh we can distill some of
the experience the online experience of
the of the robot and see how we can
incorporate that into into a sort of uh
on La ongoing Learning System
all right so this is the signature here
what if we do take this and we decrypt
it with the public key because remember
they reverse one another
and then we can sort of change their
location they can start Gathering more
information so by moving you actually
introduce uncertainty into the motion